el líder opositor ruso alexéi navalni
fue dado de alta en berlín el político
ha pasado más de un mes ingresado de los
que 24 días fueron en cuidados
intensivos su llegada a berlín se
produjo en una condición muy delicada a
causa de un envenenamiento que fue
confirmado por alemania y del que
todavía no se saben las consecuencias
según el progreso del paciente y su
estado actual los médicos tratantes
creen que es posible una recuperación
completa sin embargo es demasiado pronto
para evaluar los posibles efectos a
largo plazo de su grave envenenamiento
navalny se empezó a encontrar mal el 20
de agosto en pleno web algo que hizo
aterrizar a su avión de emergencia en la
ciudad siberiana de omsk aunque las
autoridades rusas negaron indicios de
envenenamiento posteriormente su círculo
cercano pidió su traslado a berlín donde
dio positivo por el agente nervios yo no
me echó un potente veneno que le mantuvo
en coma inducido durante semanas e hizo
temer por su vida desde la unión europea
condenaron los hechos e instaron a rusia
a investigar los pero desde el kremlin
niega en cualquier relación con lo
sucedido morir en un hospital de homs y
terminar en una morgue de homs donde se
estableciera que la causa de la
era haber vivido lo suficiente ese era
el objetivo de este astuto plan
putin me superó simplemente no se puede
engañar a sí como resultado yo estuve 18
días en coma como un tonto pero la
provocación falló navalny ha sido una de
las pocas amenazas políticas a las que
vladimir putin ha tenido que enfrentarse
en los últimos años al intentar terminar
con su hegemonía en el poder